>> THANKS.
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
>> John: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
I AM JOHN ROBERTS IN WASHINGTON.
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT
ABOUT THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION INTO
RUSSIA COLLUSION ALLEGATIONS.
THIS COMES AS THE PLOT THICKENS
IN THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBE.
HERE TO GIVE US AN UPDATE IS THE
TOP REPUBLICAN WORKING THE HOUSE
INVESTIGATION, THE TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN.
YOU ARE ENDING THE INTERVIEW
PHASE INTO RUSSIA'S MEDDLING
INTO THE ELECTION.
YOU HAVE A DRAFT REPORT OUT
TONIGHT THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
GIVE THE DEMOCRATS TOMORROW.
GIVE US THE HEADLINE.
>> THE HEADLINES ARE WE HAVE
REACHED THE POINT WHERE WE HAVE
INTERVIEWED ALL THE FOLKS WE
NEED TO.
300,000 DOCUMENTS, 73 INTERVIEWS
WE HAVE DONE, TRYING TO ANSWER
THE FOUR QUESTIONS THAT WERE SET
OUT.
YES, THE RUSSIANS TRIED TO
INTERVIEW WITH OUR ELECTION
PROCESS, YES THEY HAD CYBER
ATTACKS, ACTIVE MEASURES.
WE COULD FIND NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN EITHER
CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIANS AND WE
HAVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
SPEAK TO WHAT WE DO GOING
FORWARD.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
AMERICANS TO BE ON GUARD ON A
PROCESS SACRED TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
ELECTING OF LEADERSHIP ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
>> John: THE BIG PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE EVERYONE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT, ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
YOUR INVESTIGATION WAS STARTED
IN THE FIRST PLACE, NO
COLLUSION --
>> NO EVIDENCE.
>> NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE TERM CAMPAIGN AND
THE RUSSIANS.
>> OR THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
>> John: HOW CONFIDENT ARE
YOU?
>> WE FOUND NO REASON TO THINK
THERE IS SOMETHING WE ARE
WE HAVE TALKED TO EVERYBODY WE
FEEL WE NEED TO TALK TO.
EVERY CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION HAS ALWAYS GOT A
CAVEAT, TEN YEARS FROM NOW, A
PRIVATE DIARY MIGHT BE FOUND BUT
WE WILL ADDRESS IT AS PART OF
OUR CONSTANT OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES.
WITH RESPECT TO THESE QUESTIONS,
WE BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN REPEATEDLY TWEETING THAT IF
THERE WAS COLLUSION, THERE WAS
ON THE SIDE OF THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN WITH THE RUSSIANS.
YOU FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF THAT
EITHER.
>> NONDIRECT.
THE STEELE DOSSIER, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE IS A BRITISH CITIZEN.
HE TALKED TO SOME LEVEL OF
RUSSIANS.
HE WAS PAID BY THE DNC AND THE
HILLARY CLINTON COMMITTEE.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THERE WAS ANY
DIRECT INFORMATION PROVIDED TO
THE DNC OR HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN.
THAT MAY SPEAK TO ONE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS, THAT IS
CAMPAIGN FINANCE DISCLOSURES
PROBABLY SHOULD BE MORE FULSOME
THAN THEY CURRENTLY ARE.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HIDE
THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES BEHIND
A LAWYER'S BILL.
THERE WILL BE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE THINK
WILL SPEAK TO FULLER DISCLOSURES
AS TO WHERE MONEY IS SPENT.
>> John: OVER THE COURSE OF
THE INVESTIGATION WHICH HAS BEEN
RUNNING FOR 14 MONTHS, YOU
TALKED TO TEN PEOPLE ON THE
TRUMP SIDE OF THE FENCE AND TEN
PEOPLE ON THE CLINTON SIDE.
THE ONLY PERSON YOU DIDN'T GET
TO TALK TO HIS PAUL MANAFORT
BECAUSE HE WAS INDICTED BEFORE
YOU GOT A CHANCE TO BRING THEM
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
BASED UPON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
YOUR TALK TO, THE DOCUMENTS YOU
LOOKED AT, AND THE CONCLUSIONS
YOU HAVE COME TO BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE AT HAND, DO YOU THINK
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION COULD
POSSIBLY FIND ANYTHING DIFFERENT
THAN YOU DID WHEN IT COMES TO
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA?
>> I DON'T WANT TO GO THERE.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
HE HAS SEPARATE TOOLS AND
SEPARATE AUTHORITIES.
I HOPE HE DOES A TERRIFIC JOB.
WE DIDN'T FIND ANY EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION, AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
HE WILL EITHER.
>> John: DO YOU BELIEVE YOU
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION?
>> WITH RESPECT TO PAUL
MANAFORT, WE HAD SCHEDULED HIM
EARLY ON.
IN DEFERENCE TO MY COLLEAGUE
ADAM SCHIFF, WE DECIDED IT WAS
PREMATURE.
WE PUT OFF THAT INTERVIEW AND
THEN HE GETS INDICTED AND HE'S
BEYOND OUR REACH.
WE BELIEVE WE'VE GOT THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THE CONCLUSIONS WE'VE COME TOO.
>> John: ONE THING YOU TALK
ABOUT HIS LEAKS OF INFORMATION.
YOU TALK ABOUT PROBLEMATIC
CONTACTS BETWEEN SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY OFFICIALS
AND THE MEDIA.
DO YOU THINK THIS RISES TO THE
LEVEL OF CRIMINALITY?
>> CERTAINLY LEAKS OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ARE CRIMINAL.
IF WE FIND SOMETHING, WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO MAKE A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL IN THAT REGARD.
WE WERE HOPEFUL THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVE IN GOING AFTER LEAKS
BECAUSE IT'S CORROSIVE TO OUR
ABILITY TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO.
IT CAN BE DANGEROUS.
THIS SOUNDS MELODRAMATIC BUT
LEAKS CAN GET PEOPLE KILLED.
FOLKS WORKING ON OUR BEHALF IN
DANGER SPOTS OF THE WORLD CAN WE
PUT THEM AT RISK WHEN WE GIVE
OUT INFORMATION THAT SHOULDN'T
BE RELEASED.
WE BELIEVE THERE WAS CONTACT.
WE HAVE ONE SPECIFIC PERSON IN
THE REPORT THAT WE WILL -- THAT
MAKES THAT COMMENT.
>> John: THERE ARE DEMOCRATS
ARE NOT HAPPY WITH THE FACT THAT
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS
WRAPPING UP ITS INVESTIGATION.
ONE OF THEM IS A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
CHRIS COONS.
LET'S PLAY WHAT HE SAID.
>> THE SENATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, AS YOU RECOGNIZE,
CONTINUES TO MAKE SOLID PROGRESS
AND SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER CONTINUES TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROCESS.
I FIND THAT ENCOURAGING.
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HAS THE JURISDICTION OVER THE
FIRING OF THE FBI DIRECTOR, OVER
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
WE SHOULD BE FURTHER ALONG THAN
WE ARE.
IT'S TRULY DISAPPOINTING THAT
THOUSAND INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
IS HANGING UP HIS CLEATS.
>> John: HAVING NOT RUN THE
RACE.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE WHAT
WE HAVE DONE.
HE HASN'T BEEN PART OF ANY
INVESTIGATION.
FRAME TO MAKE THAT KIND OF
COMMENT, IT'S A BIT UNINFORMED
AT BEST.
WE ARE GOING TO BE WORKING WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE
TO GET A REPORT DRAFTED.